more than a million people have now been
infected with the corona virus around
the world 50,000 are dead one country
which so far has had a relatively low
infection races India with a population
of 1.3 billion at the country's
registered only 2,500 cases in a video
message broadcast on Friday Prime
Minister Narendra Modi tried to booster
a bolster morale in the country urging
people to light candles last week the
country introduced a nationwide lockdown
to stem the spread of the virus
DW CERN Amisha Joyce wall joins us from
the Indian capital welcome Nimisha
did mr. Modi speech include any concrete
public health protection measures no the
Prime Minister's not to get despondent
in isolation and Indian to continue to
be that despite the distance they are
united in this fight against the corona
virus but soon after the speech already
criticism flooding social media in India
and asking questions about why have
there been no concrete measures
announced and even if no what measures
why is there not more information about
India status not India's fight what is
happening about testing what is
happening about protect protective
equipment what is happening about all
those driven to hunger because of the
smog down so while the Prime Minister
encouraged Indians to stay strong in the
resolve to isolate there is also heavy
criticism of his message well the
country's three-week lockdown has been
hard for millions of migrant workers
what's their situation more than a
weekend well initially thousands fled
cities like New Delhi to get home
because they do not have food to eat in
city anymore because they do not have
work to do anymore they depend heavily
on daily wages but more than week in
activists and
that those not behind maybe people who
had stopped up food for maybe 7 days or
10 days but now they will re-emerge onto
the streets now that they're running out
of supplies despite the fact that the
police is taking measures to ensure that
these people stay in and sometimes these
are harsh measures there is this
physical violence there's there's a tax
with steaks so we went out to find out
what exactly people are doing how
exactly migrants who have been left
behind in the city now that the exodus
has slowed down to a trickle how exactly
are these people managing to survive
waiting sometimes for hours at end this
is what everyday looks like now for
these daily wage workers social
distancing boxes seem meaningless in the
face of hunger at the end of this
particular wait two oranges
none of these men are originally from
Delhi they migrated to the capital from
villages in neighboring states looking
to earn a livelihood some work in small
restaurants others at construction sites
every meal depends on the day's earnings
but with businesses closed for India's
three-week lockdown these earnings and
the meals have dried up try to go home
but all the bus stations were closed the
police told us to stay here there are no
medical services available here and we
are not allowed to leave we will have to
call an ambulance or ask the police to
let us go yet with food at hand these
men are the lucky ones the government is
providing food at hundreds of shelters
like this one yet the demand far
outstrips the supply in addition many
are physically unable to reach these
centers because of the lockdown this is
where civil society is stepping in goons
an NGO that has worked on disaster
relief during floods and earthquakes is
now adapting to a different challenge
to a disaster that cannot be seen but
that is everywhere this time far fewer
aid workers are being called in to
maintain social distancing and they're
taking up tasks they have never had
before relief work especially in the
midst of a lockdown is the government's
responsibility but workers here believe
there is no time to assign blame lives
are at stake and not just because of the
coronavirus wicked government the
government was not prepared they are
making an effort but there's a gap we
all need to work together this is now an
issue of survival new survival but even
as these groups work tirelessly to
provide protection and food to the
city's poorest the fight for survival
promises to be a long one crowding
together for shelter social distancing
is a luxury these men cannot afford but
for now at least
there is food to eat to nimisha joyous
wild nature what are India's next steps
then fighting the coronavirus of the
population in India but we also need to
hear more about testing isolation and
treatment and of course the fact that
India is not just dealing with the
health crisis but a crisis of hunger as
well good talking to you thank you for
that Namita Joyce well in Delhi okay
we'll take a look now at some more of
the latest coronavirus developments more
than a million infections have been
confirmed globally according to Johns
Hopkins University at the United States
that currently has the most active cases
a cruise ship that was stranded at sea
with covered 19 patients on boards been
allowed to dock in Florida the Zaandam
had been turned away by South American
countries and here in Germany more than
Earth
and people have died from covered 19
there are nearly 80,000 confirmed cases